Hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 nuestro invitado de hoy es el
ex Primer Ministro de Pakistán y Ram cam
quien está con nosotros desde su
residencia en lagore
está en Libertad bajo fianza desde el 13
de mayo había sido detenido unos días
antes cuando comparecía ante un tribunal
por un caso de corrupción lo que provocó
una oleada de protestas violentas y
detenciones en Pakistán señor can Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros podríamos
decir que se encuentra bajo arresto
domiciliario mientras otros casos están
pendientes
Lo pondré de esta manera estoy aislado
Porque todos mis principales dirigentes
están detenidos más de 10.000 de mis
trabajadores han sido arrestados
cualquiera que apoye al pti está
detenido o está en la clandestinidad la
gente se está escondiendo Así que
básicamente ahora estoy bastante aislado
[Música]
wright este viernes el ministro del
interior anunció que 33 de sus
partidarios habían sido entregados al
ejército para comparecer En juicios ante
tribunales militares acusados de atacar
instalaciones militares tras su
detención
y declaró en una conferencia de prensa
que usted podría ser juzgado por un
tribunal militar
Cuál es su reacción al respecto
primero voy a hablar de mi situación hay
150 casos en mi contra ahora mismo y
cuatro de los casos fueron cuando estaba
en la cárcel durante cuatro días me
metieron en la cárcel Entonces qué pasó
cuando estaba en la cárcel estaba
completamente aislado de todos los demás
cómo puede haber estado involucrado en
cuatro casos criminales cuando estaba en
la cárcel
lo que ocurre es que el gobierno y la
clase dirigente tienen miedo de que
cuando haya elecciones y este es un año
electoral en Pakistán mi partido a Racer
las elecciones
lo que están tratando de hacer es
quitarme de en medio meterme a la cárcel
y lo que han hecho ahora es esta
completa represión contra cualquiera que
sea simpatizante del pti
cualquiera que le dé fondos al partido
los trabajadores políticos es una
represión sin precedentes ahora mismo
hay gente en la cárcel incluidas mujeres
nunca en nuestra historia se había
tratado a las mujeres como ahora
la situación ahora mismo es que están
desesperados por desmantelar mi partido
el pti y una de las tácticas que están
utilizando son los tribunales militares
porque a los tribunales normales les
resulta muy difícil condenar a alguien
por estos cargos falsos por lo tanto
obtengo la bajo fianza en todos los
casos porque los casos son frívolos pero
ahora viene esta nueva táctica que son
los tribunales militares lo que
básicamente significa el fin de nuestra
democracia
como ya lo mencionó en los últimos días
varios miembros destacados de su partido
han renunciado a sus cargos entre ellos
dos exministros
es este el principio del fin del pti
debo Añadir que el ministro de defensa
dijo que el gobierno está considerando
vetar su partido por atacar al estado
primero permítame explicar la razón por
la que intentan vetar el partido
Cuál es el motivo lo que ocurrió fue que
cuando estaban en libertad de afianza
estaba en el recinto de la Corte Suprema
de slamabad
y los rangers el ejército
salieron de la nada
irrumpieron golpearon a la gente que
estaba a mi alrededor golpearon al
personal de la Corte Suprema y luego me
llevaron como si fuera una especie de
terrorista
todo fue ilegal me secuestraron cuando
las imágenes salieran iba a haber una
reacción Bueno pero desafortunadamente
Esto fue usado como cuando Y cito esto
es exactamente lo que Adolfo Hitler hizo
en 1933 cuando incendió el restark el
parlamento como una manera de aplastar a
los comunistas
eso es lo mismo que ellos hicieron
hay dos o tres edificios militares
especialmente la residencia del
comandante que se vieron afectados
debido a incendios provocados pues tome
medidas contra los implicados Cómo es
que en todo Pakistán se ha arrestado a
todo el que sea del pti más de 10.000
personas Cómo se puede restar a 10.000
personas
y ninguno involucrado en los incendios
provocados era solo un pretexto para
demorar mi partido desmantelarlo y eso
es lo que están haciendo ahora
y esto de los tribunales militares es
inaudito en una democracia significa
básicamente que nuestros tribunales
normales No funcionen o sea
Cómo puede haber tribunales militares en
una democracia
usted ha acusado al Primer Ministro y al
jefe del ejército de estar detrás de lo
que ha descrito como una Vendetta
política incluso de algunos intentos de
asesinato también ha pedido
repetidamente que se convoquen
elecciones anticipadas sin embargo supe
que esta semana Usted dijo que estaría
dispuesto a formar un comité para
negociar con las autoridades e intentar
encontrar una salida e incluso hacerse a
un lado Si fuera necesario
Esto suena como una ofrenda de paz
podría explicar exactamente de qué se
trata
mi gobierno fue destituido hace 13 meses
siempre he dicho que soy un político y
que creemos en el diálogo y que queremos
hablar
el problema es que los que me
destituyeron se asustaron de que yo
tuviera tanto apoyo público
y de las elecciones parciales que se
celebraron después
de 37 elecciones parciales ni partido
arrasó en 30 de ellas Así que los que me
destituyeron se asustaron pensaron que
se había elecciones yo volvería a ganar
y por lo tanto incluso cuando la Corte
Suprema anunció de acuerdo con la
Constitución las elecciones en la
provincia de punjah donde estoy sentado
ahora mismo que representa el 60% de
Pakistán el gobierno se negó a convocar
elecciones están huyendo de las
elecciones y mientras tanto lo que
intentan es aplastar al partido usando
estas tácticas fascistas
nunca habíamos visto nuestro país está
victimización sin precedentes que se
está produciendo ahora mismo y de hecho
lo peor es que se está desmantelando
nuestro sistema democrático porque no
están escuchando los tribunales de
Pakistán los tribunales conceden la
Libertad bajo fianza a alguien
inmediatamente ese alguien es detenido
por la policía y se le Abre otro caso mi
gente se está enfrentando a torturas
bajo custodia están viviendo en
condiciones inhumanas hace mucho calor
la gente está asignada en pequeñas
celdas y por lo tanto las palabras
mágicas que lo liberarán con las que
todos sus casos quedarán cerrados solo
tienen que decir que renuncian
que ya no forman parte del pti
eso es lo que está pasando pero Mark los
partidos políticos se debilitan cuando
los bancos devotos caen lo que está
pasando ahora es que hay más simpatía
por mi partido que nunca antes en
nuestra historia el banco de votos está
aumentando no importa si la gente va y
viene porque lo único que importa es que
en una democracia parlamentaria la gente
ganará con la papeleta del pti Y eso es
lo que va a pasar
pero está constituyendo un comité para
intentar negociar con las autoridades a
pesar de todas las acusaciones
sí o no
Sí pero no es la primera vez
Antes hubo un comité Así que hoy vuelvo
a anunciar un comité
el punto es que nuestro país está
hundiendo
nuestra economía es un desastre tenemos
la peor inflación de nuestra historia
nuestra tasa de crecimiento cayó del
6,1% al menos 1%
las exportaciones todo está bajando
todos los recaudos de nuestro gobierno
se usan para pagar nuestra deuda
Entonces estamos gobernando nuestro país
a base de deudas de más préstamos mi
punto es que ahora mismo solo por
mantenerme fuera todo el sistema se está
desmoronando
no convocan elecciones no escuchan a los
tribunales la Constitución de Pakistán
es descartada
lo que digo es por qué no entablar
conversaciones y si creen que soy una
amenaza tan para este país pues
háganmelo entender en la mesa de
negociaciones
y si no quiere convocar a elecciones
ahora en octubre en qué beneficia eso a
Pakistán nuestra economía se está
hundiendo porque si no hay estabilidad
política no hay estabilidad económica
todo lo que digo es que nos sentemos y
hablemos en lugar de esta victimización
que se está produciendo y la despiadada
persecución a mis trabajadores y a todos
mis altos dirigentes que están en la
cárcel solo pueden salirse renuncian si
abandonan mi partido
un punto importante usted mencionó las
elecciones usted pidió que hubiera
elecciones anticipadas están programadas
para octubre por lo que acaba de decir
entiendo que usted podría aceptar que
las elecciones se llevarán a cabo en la
fecha prevista que es en Octubre y No
necesariamente seguir pidiendo
elecciones anticipadas es eso correcto
inram
Marc Permítame explicar
de las cuatro provincias ni partido
estaba en el poder en dos de ellas lo
que supone el 70% de Pakistán la
Constitución dice que si se devuelve el
gobierno las elecciones tienen que ser
celebradas en 90 días lo que dice la
Constitución de Pakistán Así que disolví
mis dos gobiernos han pasado más de 90
días pero no hay elecciones porque el
gobierno se niega a celebrarlas entonces
acudimos a la Corte Suprema la Corte
Suprema ordenó que las elecciones se
realizaran el 14 de mayo el gobierno se
negó
porque el Steven en las elecciones y
tienen tanto miedo de que mi partido
arrase las elecciones que incluso están
violando la constitución del país y el
estado de derecho eso es lo que está
sucediendo ahora mismo en las dos
provincias según la Constitución
deberían haber habido elecciones no las
hubo se supone que las elecciones
principales las federales se celebrarán
en octubre lo cual está bien es
prerrogativa del Gobierno pero lo que me
preocupa es que ni siquiera vayan a
celebrar elec ciones en octubre si creen
que nosotros vamos a ganar
última pregunta ha afirmado que hubo
intentos de atentado contra su vida se
siente a salvo ahora mismo en su casa o
si tiene que ir a un juicio de nuevo
no estudias algo en absoluto porque la
gente que intentó matarme una vez cuando
recibí un disparo en la pierna intentó
matarme de nuevo el 18 de marzo en el
complejo judicial Cuando entré
tuve mucha suerte de sobrevivir porque
salí Justo a tiempo de lo contrario me
habrían matado allá y mi temor es que
saben que aunque yo esté en la cárcel mi
partido va a arrasar en las elecciones
por eso siento que habrá otro atentado
en cualquier caso no me siento a salvo
porque el gobierno que se supone que
debe protegerme está intentando matarme
Así que obviamente no me siento a salvo
Ibrahim no tenemos más tiempo quiero
agradecerle mucho que haya participado
en esta edición de la entrevista de
France 24 desde su casa en lagore
Pakistán y gracias a todos por haberla
visto
[Música]